dreharbeiten zum bushido film zeiten
ändern dich wer einen spannungsgeladenen
action-thriller erwartet wird sich
wundern
du siehst nicht irgendwie ein bushido
der als serienkiller irgendwie verstehst
du die leute da ab metzelt und ich werde
dann hier über deine rolle sondern du
siehst dort mein leben und da sei es
vorher so aus dass wir die du spaß dann
ist es jedoch unterschiede mehr
ausflügler ich stecke meine kleine
behinderte presse brachte verstand sich
verpissen sein zwei erwachsene rät heute
verkehrt er in top-hotels ist sich aber
selbst treu geblieben wie er in der
online talkshow clixoom de unter beweis
stellt denn eines hat sich nicht
geändert er hat einen wunden punkt eins
klein interview mit alice schwarzer hat
er sich eine etwas andere reaktion
überlegt jeder weiß dass man mich über
meine mutter auf jeden fall provozieren
kann und ich habe keinen bock dass ich
dann halt meist mit alice schwarzer dann
sitzen und sie merkt okay ich krieg den
hat nicht über die maschine und auf
einmal versagt sind wir waren dann die
titten damals von seiner mutter als als
kleiner junge dran gesagt hast so und
das war ein punkt gewesen so dahergesagt
ganz ehrlich weil es was fick dich ins
knie du [ __ ] so hätte ich auch so
gesagt ja klar dass wir da noch ein
punkt wo ich da nicht darauf achtet nach
motto hey lasst uns jetzt gute
miteinander reden weil wenn dieser punkt
eintritt dann gibt es nichts mehr von
wegen zeiten ändern dich und reif und
unüberlegt und entspannt dann sage ich
ganz ehrlich fick dich ins knie
jetzt im kino zeiten ändern dich der
bushido
[Applaus]